[Musique]
banal mais tout de même essentiel nous
avons tous au moins une paire mais
étonnamment elle se vante souvent à
l'unité c'est quoi l'intérêt d'acheter
juste une mitaine moi pour vous en avez
été un
coup longues en coton en silicone world
c'est dans un four chauffé 400° que
chacune des 21 une paire de mitaines a
été testé donc on a un peu chaque
fichier nommé pour vous qu'est ce qu'on
demande à une huitaine de jours avant
tout on cherche une bonne isolation
donc c'est à dire qu'on cherche à éviter
les brûlures on a regardé à partir de
quand ça devient vraiment trop chaud
piquionne brûlures imminente donc c'est
comme ça qu'on a fonctionné même s'il
est plutôt rare qu'on prenne le temps de
valser avec son gratin dauphinois selon
les modèles on ressent une brûlure en
aussi peu de temps que quatre secondes
alors que d'autres sont sécuritaires
jusqu'à 50 secondes
notre experts ne recommandent pas
limitée dans coton qui se détériore plus
rapidement et protègent moins bien sert
en silicone sont plus performantes
quoiqu'il y ait des différences
importantes
même s'il ya beaucoup de modèles c'est
avec lui qu'on il dessine comme qui sont
plus isolant que d'autres comme par
exemple je pense mandela ici la chaleur
arrive très rapidement le web seulement
lâché les plâtres le rapidement parce
que les brûlures c'est ici donc je
serais vraiment très bien performé au
départ j'ai douté j'avais l'impression
c'est en plus mince mais vraiment très
très bien autour de 35 secondes c'est
quand même assez drôle en général on
prend 3 puis on dépose directement
il y a aussi ses gains pas si élégant et
bien robuste
bien
il nous donne l'impression d'être mieux
protégés mais attention c'est ainsi le
conte qui est très fin quand même la
protection interne aussi c'est à ses
fins donc malheureusement les brûlures
qui peuvent arriver ça ces deux
compagnies différents mais en réalité
c'est très très très semblables
l'a ensuite on a testé aussi la prise en
main avec différents éléments c'est à
dire les plaques à pâtisserie on a testé
sur des casseroles des poignets des
plans céramique aussi des produits sont
des fois c'est très très très épais
presque trop épais même c'est à dire que
la prise en main difficile
c'est important c'est d'avoir des
modèles qui sont multi usages donc on
devrait pas avoir un modèle court pour
les casseroles un modèle long pour le
four donc à la maison un seul modèle qui
fait le travail pour tous pour moi c'est
suffisant on a ses petites choses le
missile qui me font beaucoup rire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez que sur les
modèles très très court j'aime beaucoup
moins que ça protège pas énormément ça
protège le bout des doigts dans un four
très chaud inévitablement les brûlures
arrive rapidement donc moi je connaisse
vraiment les modèles qui vont protéger
le haut - l'avant bras il y a aussi des
mini mitaine qui protège un peu mieux
que le minimum
dans la catégorie ten qui va protéger la
main uniquement j'ai été surpris par sa
modèle de bad ernaux vraiment avec une
belle isolation pour les poignées
vraiment là il ya vraiment une super
prise en main le néoprène aussi c'est
vraiment top au niveau de l'isolation
mais encore version chercher des choses
il faut attention aux brûlures à
novembre exactement de nouveaux
matériaux sont aussi apparus la remise
par exemple protège jusqu'à 500 degrés
seuil de la ramène à l'intérieur donc la
rabine c'est un textile que comme
capacité de vraiment d'être très
résistant par rapport à la chaleur puis
laboureur à l'intérieur c'est vraiment
et pèse donc cela même après 50 secondes
rien autre nouveau matériau le néoprène
aux dérivés du caoutchouc on trouve
quelques modèles avec que du néoprène à
l'intérieur tout nous prennent c'est
comme les costumes à dire de plongée
très mince très isolants il ya ce modèle
ci que mes collègues ont adoré par
contre un modèle qui est excessivement
petit faut prendre une bonne respiration
là pour pouvoir y entrer avec moi qu'une
grosse main là c'est difficile
d'être
exactement par contre l'isolation est
bonne j'avais des doutes sincèrement sur
ce modèle-là en néoprène et vous même
pour sortir c'est quand même assez
content
pour l'entretien plusieurs sont lavables
à la machine et quelques-unes présente
des particularités
la problématique avec le style qu'on
sait qu'en général on peut retirer les
tâches donc on peut retirer les taches
en surface mais essayer de nettoyer
l'intérieur c'est très très très
complexe j'aime beaucoup le design des
trudeau c'est la seule entreprise qui a
intégré une fermeture éclair donc ça
c'est vraiment top parce que ça facilite
le nettoyage interne par contre la prise
en main difficile et
l'isolation interne c'est excessivement
minces aussi le modèle de ricardo j'ai
bien aimé une petite lacune ça ça reste
vraiment un détail c'est le tissu bien
donc c'est à dire que le blanc là comme
ça sur les places et les black cats du
programme exactement pour ce qui est du
coup pour une paire les prix varient de
4 à 50 dollars ces modèles ce qu'ils
sont vraiment entrée de gamme au très
cher par exemple dollars à mort ou des
modèles environ à 4 dollars la paire
j'aimerais vous dire que c'est des
modèles très performants
malheureusement non les cadeaux ou
catégorie je suis le plus cher
exactement donc c'est 50 dollars la
passe et 50 dollars la paire c'est très
cher
il reste cela devint que je suis je
suspecte est votre préféré le cadillac à
cazilhac ça vraiment c'est top c'est
vraiment un super modèle vraiment ça se
rapproche
d'une qualité professionnelle
à l'intérieur on se sent complètement
protégé ça protège vraiment une bonne
partie du bras aussi le tissu est souple
pour moi c'est vraiment le top stop nous
vous suggérons également celle ci en
silicone et coton ainsi que cette paire
100 % en néoprène
aller aux fourneaux sans bobo